[Music]
my next guest is a professional chef
whose new series around the world in 80
plates airs wednesdays at 10 p.m on
bravo please welcome curtis stone curtis
thanks for being here
thanks for being here
uh what are we doing today we're gonna
make uh a treat from tuscany is that
yeah so i thought i'll teach you how to
make pasta we're gonna make fettuccine
you don't need it
we're gonna roll it out ourselves it's
actually really easy you know i don't i
know nothing i don't make pasta uh i
i've never so this is how they make
pasta this is how you do it you take the
dough and you feed it through the top
here and it comes right out the bottom
okay okay all right and what we're going
to do is we're going to loop it back
around
just catch it there you go
and make sure you don't get your finger
in there don't get your fingers in there
that's that's the dangerous part
okay so now what we're going to do
i like moving my body as much as
possible to make it look exciting while
i'm doing it you've got to get the top
and then exciting now feed the top back
into the speed right back into the two
what do you mean
i panicked let me do that again what did
i do wrong there just feed it in put it
in okay now catch it and feed it back
into the top okay like that yeah okay
okay then like that this is very
nerve-wracking now get your hand in
there okay oh that's what you use
yeah okay like that just kidding okay
and then now look conan there's a wheel
at the front here you just turn that to
the right see that wheel there just turn
that to the right okay all right all
right and then you just all right you
need to put a little bit of flour okay
andy can you take over here i'm scared
i'm not doing a good job yeah just you
you pull that one and i'll help you with
this one oh
that's it andy you're doing a good job
okay i'll rub andy and i'll do oh okay
oh no no no
no no
that's all right i don't know i don't
know what happened
i don't know something happened
okay let's go
all right so this stretches out okay
this one sort of got small again i don't
know what happened
but we'll figure it out soon and then
the idea right is once you sort of just
keep looping that through okay you're
doing a great job conan thank you now
left overlapping i'm relaxing never
gonna happen well i i just assume you
want to do it right oh wow okay
there's a lot of tension here when andy
and i cook together
all right so we did that part now what
happens then you cut it so you use that
one you cut it you turn into fettuccine
yeah let's do the cool thing where they
skip to the part where it's already
done yay look straight in there all
right the good thing about fresh pasta
is it cooks in just a minute right so
literally one minute not even not even
30 seconds i have a new scarf
fantastic andy very fast thank you very
fashionable so
30 seconds in the pan you pull it out
right and straight in you toss this
together what's in here you we haven't
said what that is that's just a source
of beautiful spring veggies so i've got
zucchini and um asparagus and all those
good things that come in spring and
summer okay right because you sort of
either the pasta you did that and then
you just said and then you dump it in
this complicated sauce well now the
sauce is actually really simple so it's
sort of not a great cooking segment if
you say then you take this and put it in
this part that took nine hours no it
didn't it didn't it's just it's carrots
unless he did something gross to the
sauce yeah he doesn't want us to know
about it that's it right you just throw
that in there you can even use tin
tomatoes what's that really it doesn't
matter you can i mean you shouldn't but
fantastic well you just said i could so
i will all right there you go have a
taste i'm gonna have a little taste
right now andy i'd like you to join me
i'm waiting for the drink oh yeah so i
thought
i should have started with a drink
that's what i should have done oh really
good it's not bad is
okay
with strawberries mint and lime right so
you go ahead and you just
i won't get statement because we're not
doing anything with eating you're making
alcohol right and i'll make you a drink
yeah a napkin
uh
right so you like this bitconner because
you basically just get in here you bump
and grind this up right bump and grind
down i'm growing so this is
you're muddling a little bit of palm
sugar all right so this is this is
called muddling right you just crunch
this up you put a little sugar in there
yeah you put a little sugar and this is
supposed to be very essential thing when
you cook right it is you like this this
is like grinding the fruit and just
grinding our hips at the same time
we're doing it together that's weird uh
this is incredible so okay
get yourself a couple of glasses okay go
ahead and pour yours in well mine isn't
done yet i want it completely muddled
and mashed up and i'm going to crush the
mice because i'm getting this all over
my suit by the way
can i crush the ice i like to smash
stuff can i do that right so just get
yourself andy keep muddling there
all right what do i do now get yourself
your cloth there all right we're going
to throw the ice in all right this is
for all of you that don't know how to
crush it i've never known how to crush
ice before i had one of those
refrigerators that does it for me right
so you get it in
which is
actually what i suggest you do at home
this seems dumb here we go just like
this right okay then what
just
damn son of a [ __ ]
it's spilling all over the floor it went
all over the floor that's not a good
idea and it's okay
very slippery here now this was a
terrible idea the ice cream use the
refrigerator that cuts the ice up for
you don't do this just really you are a
madman colonel i'm a madman oh yes
this is the part where you uh just just
put a little bit
okay
top it up with a little bit of soda and
what and that is soda soda's going in we
have to explain what we're doing so
people at home can know so
club soda and then whatever your model
so strawberries mint and lime okay is
this already in there right now or do i
put this in put that in there can i put
extra in yeah go for it all right oh man
here you go andy i'll give you a topic
disgusting all right you need it because
you're here again tomorrow yeah i am
okay let's try this out right now how
was it oh i haven't tried it yet just
settle down pal
that's been oh this is this is a straw
yeah yeah
it's a draw that's a spoon i just sucked
on a spoon and went mmm delicious
[Applause]
it does have a little kid that shows you
how completely soul-dead i've become i'm
supposed to enjoy so i enjoy
i do really good cue cards say too it's
kind of like a boozy salad yeah
these are fantastic
um now
this is great and on the show you're
going to actually uh tell us a little
bit about the show before we go so we
literally are going around the world we
take we go to 10 different countries
tomorrow night's episode we're set in
italy which is why i cooked you some
fresh pasta
and we take these contestants they race
around the world keep drinking it the
show get even better yeah um
so it's sort of like if if top chef and
the amazing race had an affair this
would be the offspring
around the world in 80 place ladies and
gentlemen congratulations curtis stone
hey thank you for being here
this is really good